vous attendez là pour l'instant que
jardin 7h40 ce matin pour la première
fois depuis plus de deux mois les
grilles du collège maryse bastié de dole
s'ouvre pour laisser entrer les élèves
au compte gouttes et après explication
de la marche à suivre
on a fait deux entrées une entrée pour
les 6e et une entrée pour les 5e donc
dès qu'ils arrivent on note leur nom
s'ils sont bien présents
normalement ils ont dû s'inscrire au
préalable et ensuite on leur donne son
âme à ce qu'ils en ont pas et ensuite
leur lave les mains donc ils puissent
rentrer dans la cour du collège
dans la cour les professeurs est la
principale sont là pour accueillir les
collégiens
je suis content de les revoir je suis
très contente de revoir mes élèves
surtout qui en a qui ont pas donné de
nouvelles depuis bas depuis le 13 mars
habituellement ce collège situé en zone
d'éducation prioritaire accueil 540
élèves
mais tous n'ont pas souhaité revenir dès
aujourd'hui
actuellement rentrer ce matin un tiers
de nos élèves du des niveaux 6e et 5e
les l'entrée se fait sur le libre choix
des familles est donc aujourd'hui dont
nous attendons à peu près 90 élèves pour
le niveau 6e 5e également enseignement
adapté compris
devenir la première heure sera consacrée
un rappel des gestes barrières à
respecter une reprise en douceur pour
des élèves parfois un peu stressé comme
miley c'est un petit moment qu'on a pas
vu nos amis on a envie de les pendre les
bras puis à c'est pas possible
la semaine prochaine ce sont les élèves
de 4e et de 3e qui feront leur rentrée
il restera alors moins d'un mois avant
les vacances d'été